Today's topic. What happen, man? Least two used to make videos together.
Danny is no longer gonna be working with Aaron. Aaron's gonna go solo.
I just don't like when you start, start threatening me,
like saying I'm like taking advantage of you and. It just kind of bothers me.
So I don't wanna be putting that situation again. Yeah.
Cause that's not how I ever was anyway. Yeah. So are we like, are we just done?
Are we done filming each other? Except figure how, like what what's next?
Like what do I do? Just make your own videos. Do good. I gotta play smart.
I gotta play a game. I gotta play the, I gotta play the LA game,
I guess for a little bit. I just gotta do it. What's the LA game.
What everyone else does need to be honest. I'm like be honest. I don't know.
I think I'm good at like starting drama. That's when I focus on starting drama,
I think I like doing drama. Selling beefs. Yeah.
I've been doing that for a long time. From the beginning.
I'm go back to this out. I have no, I don't have a filter will say anything.
You definitely don't start drama. No, I'm good at it though.
I just one thing good at no, you're not. Yes I am. I, I don't have a filter.
I will see anything. That's the thing. I don't care. I talk about gay,
so I don't care. I don't wanna filter. Dude is not good. That's gonna do it.
I have to.
That's why you didn't wanna work with him anymore. Okay, cool. Well, uh,
that's the video for today folks? Uh, tell us what you think. So this guy,
Danny Duncan, he's a YouTuber. And so this guy, Aaron,
after he left the group made Aaron left the group. You. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
they don't, they're not working with him anymore. Aaron,
not in the group anymore. He makes a video saying that Danny,
the guy who's recording, right.
Basically beat him, did a bunch of stuff. Aaron's the guy who's been saying,
I would do a bunch of drama and make stuff up if I solo.
So this is a recording before they separate. Yeah.
And afterwards he comes out with the video saying it's like me,
if I say I like drama, I like beef. You get rid of me. Then afterwards,
I go make a video saying you beat me. You stole from me. That's what happened.
So this is the recording Danny's playing. Okay. You still got the receipts.
You were showing me the.
Receipts. Yes. Well, I'm not gonna grow. I'm like my, you was a crap, man.
You do five years. You're still saying that.
I guarantee you be losing your mind at me. That makes you still like mad. He,
all you're gonna do is make yourself sad and mad. off.
You're not entitled to 5 million followers tomorrow. Oh my gotta do.
I gotta make money, man. So what, what do you think I should do?
Make good videos.
But all I'm hearing right now is that I gotta do whatever it takes to make it.
That's what we do. I guess.
That's not what you're hearing. That's what you want to hear. Yes. Okay.
You are interpreting what they're saying. However you want to hear it. They say,
do whatever you gotta do. You know what he said? Okay. I'm gonna your up.
You know what he saying? He said, I wanna play that LA game. Yeah.
Well LA I'll say anything. I have no filter. I'll see the case stuff.
It doesn't mean that you don't have a filter. It's means you have no standards.
There's a difference there. Difference.
So what's the difference between the LA game and the Miami game.
You know what I'm saying? When someone says, oh, I have no filter.
I'll say you I'm real. You're not real. You don't have no filter.
You just have no standards. You're shock. Jock.
You'll say anything to get attention. You're a clown
is what you are now. Look, some people want to make money being a clown.
That's fine.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> but there's a difference when you grab somebody else and
then drag them into your for the sake of your clown.
This man is just openly out here saying this is what he would do.
And then come to find out afterwards he releases a video.
He really didn't ruin exactly what he said he would do for cl.
Now this is to show you how much of a commodity two things are clout. Oh yeah.
And victimhood definitely.
Ever takes. Danny don't hurt. Anyone else is? I told the truth.
It's not just me that you hurt Danny. I know no one else will come forward,
but you don't deserve some of the things you have because the way you approached
it was not appropriate. Didn't hurt anyone else, man, just don't do it.
Everything I'm saying is true.
I might just make this video do to try to expose Danny,
what would that do for me?
And Danny? You can say whatever you wanna say, but long as you're honest,
just like, I've been honest this whole time. I want you to be honest as well.
I just want people to know the truth. That's it. That's all I want, period. You.
Know, it's impressive too good acting skills, the stuff he says,
you're gonna tell he prepped it. And he learned from a lot of other dramas.
Exactly what to say and what to touch on the LA game.
She pro he probably learned from the greatest.
So I don't want anybody to ever come look at me and say,
people wouldn't fake stuff. Men, women, I don't give a who it is.
People will lie through their teeth to implicate you in some. Yeah. Well,
I mean, he learned from the bad Amber heard.
Oh, you haven't seen the video either. I haven't seen the video. No,
you wanna watch it? Watch it. Well, I'm gonna put this on my second channel.
Cause I was already friends with a lot of YouTubers before that he had me
unfollow all of them, which, which to me was really weird. And I didn't like it.
He's not gonna help me if I don't do what.
He says, I'm not begging you to sign a contract.
I don't give a if he's signed a contract or not.
You're the one who wanted to make it. You're the one who wanted help.
You're the one who wanted me to help you blow the up.
I just think it looks cleaner when you're following less people. That's it.
And I don't think it matters if you're not following friends, like who gives a?
Instagram is a business. So YouTube's a business.
It's it just is him making a exposing, uh,
the truth video about me is a business. It's gonna, it's gonna get views.
It's gonna make him, you know what I mean? So, yeah.
He's been working on this video for months and months and months and months and
months I've known about it. And of course he's gonna post it, you know,
in December, which is the best month of the year for monetization. He's.
Not like <laugh>, he's not like, you know,
Louis talking about holidays, time to make some money. Let's go, Hey,
Santa's coming to town. Not for you for me. That's crazy though. Oh yeah. Yeah.
December advertisers start rolling in trying to get y'all to buy Christmas
presents.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and I start making videos so they can advertise to sell
y'all Christmas presents. You don't have to buy them <laugh> but watch.
Shout out to you. Do it all expose you
say you abuse me. <laugh> we're gonna make a.
Lot of money. Oh my God. The drama man, Danny ducking.
I'm coming for you. Next thing you know,
he starts just punching at me outta nowhere.
All I saw was a big flash.
Like a big light that's defamation.
I would.
Agree. That's defamation.
I would agree,
but it takes so much money to pursue somebody in court there it's just like,
man, I got the time. Yeah. The energy to send this money to lawyers,
to take someone who's broke to jail, not the jail to call,
which they're never gonna pay. No dude.
It's like, bro, this is a joke. Me and Aaron wrestl. We, we do jujitsu.
We do wrestling. Aarons need David in the stomach. Hey, Hey, Hey,
Hey. The only thing we ever did was just friendship around with each other.
That's it? I mean, that's kinda why I haven't replied.
Like I don't even know how to man.
I have those that actually think I abuse this kid. I'm like, what the? Imagine.
You keep punching a dog the one time, you know,
you go pet the dog and it flints. That's what I feel like with Danny.
We had to literally eat the cereal outside. We had to, we had to be so quiet.
Cause I knew if I made any type of noise, I was so scared.
He was gonna come down and beat me.
Dude, shut the up, bro. What the this dude is out of his mind.
He makes a mess with everything.
I don't think I need to play the whole video. Right?
Because I think you knows a bunch of non text.
What I think is important is you absolutely lose all credibility.
When you get on video or you get recorded saying I'd make up anything.
I'll say anything to get some views, some clap. Uh, don't be so surpris.
When people think you just said anything to get some views, some cl sorry,
you lost all credit. All of it.
And you know the unfortunate part about this whole thing is that when he came
out with this video, a lot of people jumped out. He like, that's terrible.
Of course that's why you left. You must be telling the truth.
This guy's a piece of. And some people gonna get confirmation by. I owe,
he knew Danny was the worst person. I don't know what I'm to say.
I always knew Danny beat people.
Cause one time I saw the way he touched you in the video at three F.
But they do that. They do that on our video. They do. They think they,
they do that on our videos all the time. Oh, you see, did you,
did you see the way that he looked and the side looked,
did you see the way he's you guys.
This is what you call parasocial relationships.
Where the people who are watching us think that they know was better than they
actually do. And they're convinced that they're, you know what I'm saying?
Not mad at you. I mean, do what you want. It's fine.
But I think it's fascinating. Yeah, it is that he came out the video. Everybody.
Immediately believed, but that's the thing is like, imagine to have a group, uh,
whether it's a sending group or duo like ourselves and like that, there's a lot,
you have to understand. There's a lot of things that we have to talk about.
Whenever you feel some type of way, there some,
you have to put that on the table right now. Right.
And it's not to bring that back, but it kind of is that.
And that's the reason why we say that we're not friends and we're colleagues.
Cause the feelings do not get hurt. You know what I mean?
It's about the business. If I do some wrong,
he tells me bluntly, it's about the business.
It ain't got nothing to do with feelings.
You don't want to hurt your BR your be your best bros feelings or whatever.
That's what, we're not. It's really that.
And it's crazy because of the way we met when we started this,
we didn't know each other. We kind of, we we're lucky.
I'm lucky that you're not a piece of. Well, you're not a total <laugh>
to expose you. <laugh> and you're, and, and you're looking,
and I'm not a total piece of because of the, of,
of everything that we go through, all the, all this.
Guys. I want you guys to note this exact moment. And this day on the video,
this, I want you guys to quote it and put in the comments right now.
This is exactly where this channel died right here. What he just said,
right? When I go solo and I make my exposed video, you wonder like, yo,
what happened this moment right here is what caused it.
Go ahead. What caused it? They know they saw you so right.
I always knew it. This <laugh>,
but that's pretty much it like with, with everything that's involved.
People always talking, the DMS, the, this and that, that he say,
she said to all of that, the money, all it could have been,
it could have been wrong. It could have been, it could,
it could turned sour real quick.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> <affirmative> it could turn sour real quick.
There's I could see just, um, the opportunities of going wrong.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> I was just, yeah, I see the opportunity going on.
Because at the end of the day, it's two humans at the end of the day,
you don't know who you, who you got, what morals they got, you know what I mean?
Mm-hmm so yeah, it's up.
Yeah. And, and, and I think like the big lesson to take away from this,
if we can reinforce this a hundred thousand times,
it's like people lie to be victims. I, I remember,
I remember like a couple years back, people like who would make up a lie to,
to be seen as if anybody's majority of people, anybody.
Yes.
Cause guess what? There's power in being a victim. Whether you,
we don't believe it or not. I really don't care.
I know because there's evidence everywhere around us.
will lie at the drop of the dime for frivolous and make a big old lie makes
everything way worse. Cuz they don't want to lose their victim status.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> in whatever situation they do it in relationship,
they do it in dating. They do it in workplaces. They'll do it in any scenario.
So just be mindful that when someone tells you a story and you're just like,
man, why would this person lie? It's like, there's plenty of reasons.
There's plenty of reasons to lie. And as far as this situation goes, you know,
shout out to him for recording those conversations.
And that's not something I would think of doing,
but I have friends who are content creators who told me they record a bunch of
their conversations cuz they're like preparing receipts in case anybody says
system up. Of course. And I understand it. I get it. I understand it. You know,
for me, it's just like, it's a little too weird. I can't get myself to do it,
but I'm pretty sure if I was in a compromising situation where I started
sniffing some out, I'll be like, right.
Let me hit the record button just to cover my because you I'll tell you this
I've deleted certain conversations that I regret deleting mm-hmm <affirmative>
cause I'm like, if that comes back, I got no receipts. Yep. You know?
And it's one of those things where I'm like, Ooh, okay. Okay. I might have, I,
I should probably should have kept that conversation cuz this person acting a
little weird now. Mm. You know what I'm saying? They changing, they tune.
But anyways, I digress.
Good on him for providing those receipts and clearing his name.
I think it's unfortunate that we're so quick to jump at someone's neck.
Just because somebody said some, but yeah. You know,
that's that's the world we live in. Anything else you want add? No. All right.
Well, there you go. And guys don't get caught up in this cloud. I find it.
So CR when people want to make like, you know,
that was the saddest thing when he said I get so it mad when I make my channel,
it doesn't grow. It's okay to fail. It's and it's okay to.
Keep workings. It's part of the process, man. Yeah. Oh.
It's like people are addicted to the success.
They don't like any of the labor that comes with it and constantly working at
it, trying to improve. They just want the result. They want to be on there.
The yacht and having a good time. <laugh> don't they know it is though.
The guy told 'em too was like, you're not tied out to 5 million followers. Duh.
Yeah. We're not entitled to anything.
That's why even at almost 2 million followers, I'm not sitting here.
Like of course. Yeah. I could be at a hundred thousand. I'm like, cool.
I appreciate y'all. I appreciate y'all. This is be grateful.
I never thought we'd get here. And I never thought we'd get even further.
I'm just like, Hey, I'm cool with whatever.
So some of y'all gotta humble yourselves.
You guys are very entitled when it comes to like followings and numbers and all
this stuff. It's like, you are looking at it the wrong way.
People told me this the other day. He's like, yeah, you just say that,
cuz you got all these subscribers, bro.
Do I talk differently today than when I had 100,000.
No thousand. It is the same thing.
By homie. See me? They know I talk, oh yeah, the subscribers. No, when they.
When they meet me in the real life. Oh they're they're like, okay,
you're the same dude. Like this is not that, yes, this is not a,
this is not a thing of special faith that I put. We,
we turn this off and then I'm gonna talk the same. You know what I mean?
And that's the thing. So yeah. You know, it's not it's, it's always been that,
that that's it.
So that's why that's actually why I'm very careful of not exposing everything
that I do in my personal life. Right. Cause this is already real.
It's already real. It's already a real thing. You know what I mean? So yeah,
it is what it is anyways.
Well, let us know what you guys think in the comments below.
We want to hear from you. What do you think about this whole situation? Come.
Hey sir, stop recording. Huh?